Tony asks Gary what are your thoughts
about people that stay companies like
Twitter uber and snapchat are way
overvalued in the market Tony what's
really interesting about this question
is I am one of those people I grew up in
the late and mid 2000s into the 2010s 11
12 13 thinking a lot of things were
overvalued I thought we were at a little
bit of a bubble in 2010 11 I've been
proven to be extremely wrong what I
would tell you is is that inflation
happens I mean like that the world
changes like I'm starting to wrap my
head around the notion of wait a minute
maybe these things are undervalued
because you know the value of a hundred
million dollar company just 15 20 30
years ago was a far grander and wealth
just continues to exponentially grow and
so you know I would say that it's a
double-edged sword there'll be plenty of
things overvalued tons but if something
is proven to have won and you think is
the future of infrastructure Allah and
uber where you can clearly see them
getting into the FedEx and UPS as lanes
and other places you know plenty of
people have lost a lot of money by
thinking things were overpriced and I
want you to listen to that backwards one
more time and so rewind it whether
you're listening or watching you know a
lot of people have lost a lot of money
by thinking things have been overvalued
and of course there's the yin to that
yang and people have lost him betting on
overvalued things but when things hit
scale Amazon and eBay in the early days
of the Internet where people thought
they were overvalued but the world
caught up to them be careful if the
world is catching up to something
what I mean by that is if you start
watching normal people doing things on
some of these platforms you're gonna see
a scale jump and so you are they
overvalued if there's a crash in the
market right or a terrace back in a
major city can it be overvalued of
course but is that temporary is the real
question
and when I say temporary don't
misunderstand me is it overvalued and
it'll go down for a year but then go
back up because they're living in the
future while other things are not Oh
Brad wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe